one of the best-kept secrets of Memorial
wedding who will design naked markle's
bridal gown meanwhile we had some of the
most famous dress makers in the world
weigh in on what they think
Meghan wear today yes yes to the dress I
have a feeling we'll see something you
know a little bit modern I don't think
it's gonna be a traditional kind of
old-school bridal gown I also would
understand if she chooses to wear Co
British I mean she's joining the royal
family but would it make me happy to see
where an American yes with a billion
people expected to be watching live
designer Reem Acra says naked should go
for bi G big it's once-in-a-lifetime the
whole world is watching you need to have
a statement wearing white for her royal
I do is as an etiquette no no according
to romona Keveza given the fact that
Meghan is marrying for the second time
she can wear pearl but she can't wear
white shades of off-white like cream
moister and pearl are considered
suitable and chic this lovely pearl
crepe dress it's very simple but yet
very regal that I think would look
lovely on her it suits her figure type
but there seems to be an unwritten rule
when it comes to royal wedding gowns no
bare arms
Kate Middleton's Alexander McQueen gown
had long lace sleeves
so today while many bridal shows feature
strapless sleeveless and plunging
necklines don't expect Megan to go for
an overly sexy look you know I think she
will definitely kind of push the
envelope but I think she'll be
definitely respectful to the royal
family and you know to the UK in general
nothing will be too exposed I think she
might go little more form-fitting I
think she's gonna redefine princess
[Music]